[Music]
she too
i uh
you don't speak romaine
[Music]
you don't like
no it's lovely
there's this guy that lives across the
street and he's always looking over here
looking over here how
every time i look over there he's just
staring right at me
[Music]
hello darling
any reason in particular you're standing
in the dark
do you feel like coming in for a drink
yeah have you noticed anyone watching
you in your apartment no
this guy has been watching us since we
moved in
maybe he's staring at the woman who's
staring at him
[Music]
what's happening
they found a woman murdered in her
apartment they're saying the woman had
her head cut off
it's a man at the movie theater followed
me into the supermarket followed you
that's him
i need to know for myself that he's been
following me
sometimes i
just look at people
just tell me what you want me to want
you to believe me
i'm sure that you'd see me
i heard screaming from in here okay just
open the door please
dreaming about pretty girl
looking back at me
but no one has really noticed before
[Music]
[Music]
you